hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science here chemistry phd and skin care
nerd
if you like nerding out about the
science behind beauty products then you
can click the subscribe and the
nerdification bell
and check me out on instagram as well
today i'm talking about my collaboration
box with wishtrend
i chose some of my favorite products
from their catalog and you can pick them
up at a discounted rate
this box is called the boost your base
box i'm really bad at picking out names
as you can probably guess from
lab muffin beauty science it has four
full-size products for 55.50
which is 40% off the normal price if you
bought these products individually
it also comes with free international
shipping and four bonus sheet masks
so here's the idea behind the products i
picked we all have access to lots of
high-powered active ingredients and we
pick them based on our skin concerns so
acne hyperpigmentation anti-aging that
sort of thing
as i've said a few times before i think
we all tend to go a bit ham on our skin
so we just blast it with really
high-powered actives
and so that means a lot of us tend to
bounce between using really high-powered
actives and then freaking our skin out
and then we have to jump to using the
blandest bland products until our poor
sensitized skin
recovers and so we bounce around a whole
bunch and then eventually hopefully we
reach a happy medium
so i picked out a whole bunch of
in-between products so these are gentle
and soothing but they still have lots of
actives in them
so you don't feel like you're wasting a
night even though you are letting your
skin rest a bit
and they should work for a lot of people
i didn't want to tempt people into adding
yet another
really irritating product into their
routine that their skin didn't
necessarily need
but i also wanted these products to be
really enjoyable to use
and so that way having these products on
hand means that you're hopefully a bit
less tempted to just smash your skin
every night with the strongest actives
possible
because i know that feeling so the first
product that i picked for the box that i
knew i had to include
is the klairs soft airy uv essence
this is a sunscreen that i've had in my
holy grails list for a really long time
i'm sure you all already have a
sunscreen in your routine but
we have to use a lot of sunscreen so
it's a product you'll probably be able
to use up
this is a light water-based sunscreen
and it has a really nice texture
it's also alcohol-free alcohol isn't
really bad for your skin but if it's
irritated it can sting a little bit
it's a chemical sunscreen that uses some
of the newer photostable filters
including one of my favorites
uvinul a plus it has a light scent no
white cast
and it's rated spf 50 plus and pa plus
plus plus
plus which is the highest rating you can
get for korean sunscreen
as well as protecting your skin from uv
there's also some skincare ingredients
in it there's sea buckthorn oil which
has antioxidants to protect your skin
from free radicals
there's also allantoin beta glucan and
niacinamide which are all really good at
soothing skin
it works really well for everyday use
under makeup and it also works really
well over makeup so you can reapply it
using a cushion
it's actually the sunscreen that i used
in my demonstration
for how to reapply sunscreen over makeup
the next product is by wishtrend's
mandelic acid 5%
skin prep water if you're a skincare
nerd you probably already have an alpha
hydroxy acid exfoliant in your routine
most of the time when you have aha
exfoliants you have
lactic acid and glycolic acid mandelic
acid is a bit harder to find
it's a really gentle alpha hydroxy acid
it's larger so it
has a bit of a harder time getting into
your skin and so it's less likely to
cause irritation
it's also got a really low concentration
of five percent so this is really good
to use when your skin is irritated but
you still want to exfoliate a little bit
it also has a bunch of soothing
ingredients in it we have
beta-glucan panthenol licorice fruit and
centella extracts
so this is really good if your skin
needs a little bit of a break but not
that much of a break then we have the
klairs midnight blue calming cream
this is a really popular korean beauty
product it's
really amazing at soothing irritation so
it's really good if you've got chapped
skin or if you've gone too hard on
actives
it has this really pretty blue color
which comes from the active
guaiazulene this is a natural product that
comes from chamomile and it's really
good at calming down skin
it's also got centella extract which is
great at healing your skin
and amazingly it doesn't have
niacinamide it's getting really hard to
find products that don't have
niacinamide in them
and so if you want to give your skin a
break from niacinamide or if your skin
doesn't like niacinamide that much
this is a really nice product to use
there's lots of humectant moisturizers
in this
these are really good at holding water
to your skin especially if your skin's
dehydrated they're really great so
glycerin and hyaluronic acid
there's also some moisturizing oils like
jojoba oil argan oil and shea butter
the texture of this is slightly thicker
than a gel
but i didn't find it oily or greasy it
also has no noticeable scent
then we have the by wishtrend quad
active boosting essence
this is a really lightweight soothing
toner usually i'm a bit hesitant with
plant extracts because they can be
irritating
but when a product purposely chooses
soothing calming plant extracts that's
not really a problem
using plant extracts is a really good
way of getting a huge range of
antioxidants into a product and so
having this variety of antioxidants
means that it's more likely to work
and the antioxidants can keep each other
activated inside the product so they
last a bit longer
this has lots of plant extracts that
soothe skin so we have willow bark corn
flour magnolia berry
white mulberry bark and lotus there's
also fermented honey and black tea in
this
and propolis so propolis is made by bees
from tree sap
and contains lots of antibacterial
compounds this is also another product
that doesn't have niacinamide so if you
have
niacinamide-sensitive skin then this
is fantastic because it's quite hard to
find soothing products that don't have
niacinamide in them these days
so this has humectants but it's not very
humectant which is nice because you can
pat it onto bare skin
it leaves a slightly tacky texture but
then you don't really feel like you have
any sort of layer on your skin
so it's really easy to wear under
sunscreen under makeup in between layers
you can just slot into your routine
without having to worry about it
interacting with things
or making your skin feel heavy there are
also four sheet masks
here they are the midnight blue calming
sheet mask and the rich moist soothing
tencel sheet mask
there are two of each in the box sheet
masks are a staple of korean skin care
and i think it's one of the really nice
entry points into korean skin skincare
they're really hydrating and hydration
is a big thing in korean skin care
they're also quite fun they're good for
perking up your skin if you have a
special day the next day
they also have a bit of an occlusive
function so you put it on your skin and
it helps the things underneath absorb
more
effectively so keeps your skin hydrated
and it sort of pushes your actives into
your face
so the midnight blue calming sheet mask
is similar to the calming cream
except it's got slightly different
ingredients but it's for the same sort
of purpose so it's good for cooling down
your skin
and soothing irritation we also have the
rich moist soothing tencel sheet mask
this is a bit more moisturizing as you
can tell from the name it has
five different types of ceramides we
also have aloe vera and hyaluronic acid
for moisturizing we also have lots of
soothing actives in this so things like
licorice extract
panthenol allantoin and centella so
there's a link in the description to buy
this i do get a commission for each box
if you want to get the free
international shipping use the code COMEHERE
so if you think these products might be
a good addition to your routine
hopefully i saved you some money
and i hope you enjoy the products